που να ποσυμφορίσουν του εντι δεμόσια αν υπηρεσί γιη οποία δημόσεια τού τη υπηρεσία ξεκίνησε
των το κακόν που τον καιρόν του μαγαρύ μάυτός που οτα ου το έσαρέντε που
τα κόμματα από του σόσος σδήπλα τους και πορεά σε πουλύσα ιοικογένειας ραμόνα και τα
υο τα μοράσεις ο γιος ος κορη ενδυνάμησου ενώς ενώστόχος ενο λόγος να σικώνε σε
το προίνι ναπαλεύκηση φίλεμεναντττουτι αλλαγή που κάμαστη ζωή μου να ξέρεις που εξεκίνησα το ιο
και γιασενια έγινε για ότόν τον λόγο βασιλάγάέγινε για τα παιθιάμου δηλαδή το πιχειγιασενια ας
πούμε ένας που μεγνώριζε και βλεπε με τόλαοήμονο υ πραξισμοό αλλά και φάτσαμου ήταν λε
πεσέραμε μαύρους κύκλους που το τσιάρον καιτα λοιπά καιας πούμε και ήταν τότε πάρχια σατα
αγάπνω κι εγώ ίδιοσεραβίας πός ότι το ι κιαενια διαγνώστηκαμε δέκα ευδιανοητικές διαταραχές λοιπόν και
ήταν τότε π κατάλαβε ότι τα παιθκιά μας πορω τα μεγαλώσουμε με το με το
ότι τους λαλούμε διαδήτα ένα μπορώ με στο σπίτρ εφιλότι θέλεις πέτιο και καταλάβει τώ
πορών μεγαλό βλέποντας τι κάνουν ιγωνίς τουν το άλθα και το μέδτις πράξη ου και
και πακαι αποφάσεισα ότι θέλοντα ευθέλω τα μορά μου να περάσουν τούτα που πέρασε εγώ
και γαματόν το πράγμα δηλαδής και ακολούθησε με καιρα μόνα και πράβο της έρα μόνα
στου το κρύποτη πίες σε κέντρο και κλείστηκε για και ηνα θεματισμένη που σ παπριν
τις συν εξάρτηση των το πράγμα που το εχα κε εγώ γιατί είναι ησυνεξάρτηση συνεξάρτηση
εφιλέεείναι μια πάθηση που στην αμερική να έχεική νοσοκομία το μέτο ας πούμε που εναι
πιαμέλω ότι γαμέι διευθύντρια είαι για της συνεξάρτηση τιο το πράντι είναι μία γυναίκα συν
εξαρτημένι ενάρτι να παντρευτεί ένα ανάντρα ανεθισμένο εξαρτημένο να τίχτε δηλαδή ανείς εκουμαρίς αλκολικός καπνιστείς